la dynamique de la politique américaine
pourrait radicalement changer dans les
prochains jours d'abord avec les
élections de mi-mandat qui vont avoir
lieu mardi et aussi on a appris que dans
le Trump envisage d'annoncer sa
candidature pour les prochaines
présidentielles 2024 dans 10 jours Sonia
Dridi et Raphaël Jacob sont avec nous ce
soir Bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir bonsoir
On va commencer avec le scrutin de mardi
donc à quelques jours des élections
mi-mandat ou les démocrates pourraient
perdre le contrôle de la Chambre des
Représentants et du Sénat c'est avoir
quand même mais Raphaël l'enjeu est
majeur pour Joe Biden il est majeur et
en plusieurs volets peut-être les deux
plus importants les deux plus centraux
Caroline sont les suivants premièrement
l'aspect législatif de la chose c'est à
dire que c'est le Congrès on doit
toujours le rappeler c'est pas le
président des États-Unis qui légifère à
proprement dit c'est le Congrès ce sont
les deux chambres du Congrès donc par le
fait même à partir du moment où le parti
adverse à partir républicain reprend le
contrôle ne serait-ce que d'une seule et
deux chambres du Congrès et on lui
confère vraiment un droit de veto sur à
peu près tout ce que le président Biden
pourrait vouloir voir accompli d'un
point de vue législatif pour la fin de
son premier mandat peut-être de son
unique mandat donc il y a ce volet là le
deuxième volet est également extrêmement
important c'est celui du pouvoir
d'enquête avec la majorité que ce soit
la chambre que ce soit au Sénat ou avec
les deux le parti républicain aurait le
pouvoir de lancer de mener ou même de
mettre fin à des enquêtes
entamées par la majorité démocrate donc
concrètement ce que ça veut dire je vous
donne un exemple mais c'est un exemple
parmi plusieurs c'est seulement
peut-être le plus remarquable tout ce
qu'on a fait dans le cadre du comité
d'enquête spécial sur le 6 janvier ça a
été mis
sur pied par les démocrates à la Chambre
il y a assez fort à parier que si ou
plutôt quand les républicains reprennent
le contrôle de la Chambre ils vont
carrément mettre la clé dans la porte
absolument donc c'est considérable pour
la suite des choses et puis pour y avoir
des enquêtes ensuite sur des membres de
la famille de Joe Biden son
administration alors oui c'est ça donc
ça changerait quand même tout autour
tout si les démocrates avaient le vent
dans les voiles en juin dernier là quand
on parlait de la Cour suprême qui a
invalidé l'arrêt l'eau contre Wade
concernant l'avortement Sonia le vent a
tourné les républicains pourraient fort
probablement prendre le pouvoir de la
chambre de représentants et c'est là
donc on en a parlé le ça changerait
complètement la dynamique pour Joe Biden
oui tout à fait selon les prédictions
les républicains vont très certainement
reprendre le contrôle de la Chambre des
Représentants et d'ailleurs beaucoup
s'attendent à ce scénario ici à
Washington j'ai même parlé avec des gens
qui travaillent à la Maison Blanche et
il s'attendent à ce que les républicains
reprennent le contrôle de la chambre
jusqu'à présent les démocrates espérés
au moins pouvoir rester maître du Sénat
alors on voit ces derniers temps que il
y a beaucoup de courses très serrées et
il n'est pas sûr que les démocrates
puissent
maintenir leur le contrôle du Sénat
alors si perdre la chambre et le Sénat
c'est le scénario catastrophe pour les
démocrates parce que la fin du mandat de
Joe Biden sera complètement
paralysé un quasi paralysé et puis c'est
vrai que vous parliez du sujet de
l'avortement c'est sûr qu'on a senti
après l'été au moment de l'été vraiment
une remobilisation du camp démocrate qui
était moins mobilisés ces derniers temps
on sait que je Biden une popularité qui
avoisine 40% même chez les démocrates il
y a pas un grand enthousiasme pour le
président le sujet de l'avortement a
vraiment remobilisé il y a d'ailleurs
beaucoup de femmes qui se sont inscrites
sur les listes électorales après le la
remise en cause de la révolution de
notamment par exemple dans des états
clés comme la Pennsylvanie mais on a
senti finalement que cet élan c'est un
peu échaudé ces derniers temps et ce qui
préoccupe beaucoup les électeurs et
avant tous les acteurs américains c'est
l'économie les questions de sécurité et
c'est là où ça pêche pour les démocrates
c'est vraiment l'enjeu l'enjeu de l'urne
si on peut dire là c'est vraiment
l'économie l'inflation les difficultés à
joindre les deux bouts pour les
électeurs donc vraiment des
préoccupations qui les touchent jour
après jour on a parlé de la Chambre des
Représentants on va parler maintenant du
Sénat on va regarder ensemble la
composition actuelle parce qu'on est
presque à 50 50 finalement là si on
inclut les indépendants du côté
démocrate avec l'aide de Kamila Harris
comme vice-président finalement on est à
50-50 du côté du Sénat Raphaël il y a 35
sièges qui sont en jeu en ce moment 21
qui sont républicains 14 qui sont
démocrates à quoi est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre pour le Sénat on peut
s'attendre à une soirée absolument
palpitante je peux mettre la barre 3
hautes mais considéré ceci on est à 55
ans de vous mentionnez un instant
Caroline ce que ça veut dire
concrètement c'est que les républicains
ont besoin de faire un grand total d'un
gain net au Sénat pour reprendre la
majorité un seul gain un seul gain or
considéré ceci il y a cinq courses
présentement je vous dirais où l'issue
et très difficile à prédire avec
confiance dans ces cinq courses là qu'on
regarde l'agrégation des sondages la
moyenne des sondages aujourd'hui à 4
jours du vote dans 4 de ces 5 course là
on est à 1 point d'écart au moins entre
le candidat républicain candidat
démocrate donc ça peut Raphaël on a
préparé la carte on va regarder ensemble
les cinq États dont vous nous parlez là
où il y a vraiment des luttes à
surveiller on les voit à l'écran et
d'envoi d'ailleurs d'abord avant tout à
quel point c'est ces diversifié d'un
point de vue géographique d'un point de
vue politique et donc où je crois les
démocrates ont un défi considérables
devant eux c'est que pour maintenir leur
majorité il doit gagner ils doivent
espérer gagner au moins quatre de ces
cinq sièges-là alors que le momentum on
disait il y a un instant également
semble clairement depuis les derniers
jours les dernières semaines dans le cas
républicain donc c'est pas possible
c'est certainement beaucoup plus placé
pour les démocrates d'espérer gagner le
ou de regagner le contrôle sinon que de
la chambre mais je voudrais qu'à l'heure
actuelle je le maintiens je m'en
souviens pas très froid la semaine
dernière le verdict est le même en ce
qui me concerne les républicains
devraient quand même être considérés
comme étant favori peut-être pas autant
de fois qu'à la chambre mais néanmoins
dans une meilleure posture quels sont
les démocrates pour le contrôle du Sénat
également et j'ajoute également ceci qui
est important je crois au niveau des
implications parce qu'on se parlait de
des impacts législatifs des impacts au
niveau des enquêtes publiques il y a
également ceci qui vient avec la
majorité au Sénat le pouvoir d'approuver
ou de au contraire de les nominations du
président ça s'implique également au
tribunaux incluant la Cour suprême donc
c'est extrêmement important c'est pas
simplement que ça aurait été interprété
comme une dégelée c'est démocrate perdre
également le Sénat c'est que pour
Monsieur Biden ça va le paralyser même
jusqu'à dans sa possibilité d'effectuer
des nominations qui entre en vigueur
après coup donc finalement ça pourrait
paralyser tout ce qui va vouloir faire
essentiellement et donc on a vu cette
semaine Joe Biden plaidait pour l'avenir
de la démocratie on voit Sonia Barack
Obama qui est sur le terrain on sent
vraiment que ça chauffe du côté
démocrate puis on essaie de faire
renverser la vapeur est-ce que c'est
encore possible à votre avis
alors c'est vrai on le sent vraiment du
côté démocrates on fait tout pour tenter
de mobiliser les électeurs qui ne sont
pas encore une fois franchement
enthousiasmés par la même chez les
démocrates par Joe Biden c'est pour ça
qu'on fait appel à Barack Obama l'ancien
président c'est pour ça que Joe Biden
tente vraiment de faire de cette
élection un test pour la démocratie le
dit le répète il employé d'ailleurs des
mots qu'il a et des expressions qu'il
avait utilisé pendant sa campagne
électorale en disant qu'il fallait
sauver l'âme de la nation
ça a un petit peu moi j'ai été par
exemple en Pennsylvanie il y a quelques
il y a quelques semaines parler à des
électeurs et on sent que les grandes
préoccupations c'est à la fois
évidemment l'économie mais aussi
beaucoup se disent quand même
perturbé par tout ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis par la violence politique
également et par le fait que l'autre
camp chez les républicains et bien je
crois plus pour beaucoup à cette
démocratie donc ça marche un petit peu
mais ça marche déjà en fait finalement
chez les gens qui sont convaincus et si
Biden et le camp démocrate tant d'aller
chercher de la voix des indépendants
notamment ou des républicains modérés
qui seraient déçu qui ne seraient pas
forcément content de leur candidat dans
leur état c'est difficile parce que là
et là byden n'est pas aidé par la
conjoncture entre avec cette inflation
très importante c'est là où ça pêche
donc c'est vrai qu'on voit que
il y a il y a une tentative du côté
démocrate de vraiment tout faire pour
remobiliser
l'électorat de mettre la démocratie au
cœur de ce scrutin mais quand on parle
aux Américains voilà c'est pas leur
préoccupations majeure même si sa
préoccupe certains c'est pas pour ça
forcément qu'ils vont se déplacer aux
urnes non c'est ça mais qu'est-ce qui
pourrait faire changer la donne Raphaël
à votre avis est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est encore possible de faire
en trois mots Caroline je l'ignore
pour un mot ça fait trois
on a tout essayé du côté démocrate
depuis les derniers jours et ça en soit
je crois c'est extrêmement illustratif
des problèmes que le parti ne serait-ce
qu'un point de vue comme communication
politique donc on essaie présentement
beaucoup beaucoup l'argument
démocratique il faut défendre la
démocratie il faut sauver la démocratie
c'est peut-être même selon les propos de
Barack Obama d'Arizona il y a quelques
jours c'est peut-être la dernière
élection réellement démocratique on va
avoir aux Etats-Unis donc on essaie
beaucoup ce message là il y a un mois
deux mois trois mois on a parlé à peu
près que l'avortement là dans les
dernières semaines on a parlé aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de la défense des
programmes sociaux comme quoi c'est les
républicains redevenez majoritaires ou
concret et on irait sabrer dans ces
programmes-là les démocrates ont essayé
sur le bout des lèvres de parler un
petit peu des fois d'économie donc
écoutez à peu près c'est un concept une
règle politique assez élémentaire
surtout lorsqu'on s'approche de façon
aussi rapprochée justement d'un scrutin
le parti qui est en train constamment de
changer un message est rarement le parti
qui est dans une bonne posture dans la
panique ça sent la panique encore une
fois pour revenir à votre question de
départ est-ce qu'il y a une poignée
vraiment ce statique pour sauver les
meubles de façon appréciable si on a une
à ce statique du côté démocrate je ne la
vois pas bon et pendant ce temps-là il y
a l'ancien président des États-Unis dans
Donald Trump qui est encore beaucoup
d'influences en ce moment chez les
républicains qui pourraient annoncer
dans une dizaine de jours qu'il va se
présenter au présidentiel 2024 donc 10
jours ou quelques jours en fait après
les élections demi-mandat ce qu'on veut
faire de son côté Sonia c'est c'est de
surfer sur la possible vague de victoire
qui va y avoir pour les républicains la
semaine prochaine
oui tout à fait et il faut le dire
Donald Trump parle de cette possibilité
d'Adams et de sa candidature depuis des
mois déjà et ce qu'on sait c'est que au
sein du parti républicain notamment un
petit peu chez l'élite républicaine on
l'a prié de ne pas annoncer sa
candidature avant l'élection les
élections de mi-mandat de peur que c'est
ça ait une influence scrutin pas
forcément dans leur sens et donc Donald
Trump attend et piétine depuis des mois
pour annoncer sa candidature et donc
selon les dernières informations
notamment provenance du site d'axo s'il
pourrait le faire donc le 14 novembre ou
en tout cas d'ici la fin du mois et
l'idée en effet ça serait de surfer sur
ce momentum qu'on les républicains et et
donc c'est c'est un scénario très très
possible très envisageable et comme vous
le disiez il a une influence énorme sur
ces élections de mi-mandage je crois
qu'il y a environ 200 candidats cette
année qui sont soutenus par Donald Trump
d'ailleurs ça crée des divisions au sein
du parti républicain parce que les plus
modérés s'en inquiète s'inquiète de voir
tous ces élus très pro Trump avec pour
beaucoup ceux qui défendent des tests
conspirationnistes arriver au Congrès et
c'est là où vraiment l'image la
politique américaine va être encore plus
influencé si on a tous ces nouveaux élus
ou sénateurs pro Trump qui arrive au
Congrès là encore l'impact sur la
politique américaine et sur la vie
démocratique va être très impactée et ça
ça veut dire en même temps que c'est une
campagne présidentielle qui commencerait
à ce moment-là pour Donald Trump une
campagne de deux ans Raphaël
essentiellement écouter si vous pensez
que c'est long il faut se rappeler qu'en
2020 pour la campagne de 2020 on a eu
des candidats une candidate en
particulier en particulier pardon madame
Warren du côté démocrate qui a annoncé
sa campagne présidentielle normalement
de sa campagne présidentielle en
décembre de l'année précédente autrement
dit en fait descendre pardon qui suivait
directement les élections mimanda donc
c'était essentiellement une campagne de
deux ans donc ça serait pas la première
fois de un et de deux pour de l'argent
il y a au moins deux incitatifs majeurs
pour annoncer une candidature très
rapidement après le scrutin de mardi
prochain le premier instatif il est de
nature simplement politique et
électorale c'est-à-dire dissuader le
plus possible le plus rapidement
possible d'autres possibles aspirants
républicains et on va surtout garder
d'ailleurs du côté de la Floride du
gouverneur de Santis en un bon score
électoral mardi prochain donc il y a ça
et aussi un institutif d'un point de vue
juridique c'est-à-dire dissuader la
justice américaine de l'inculper parce
qu'à partir du moment où il devient
candidat présidentiel ce n'est pas
impossible mais ça devient beaucoup plus
sensible d'aller passer les menottes
pendant l'expression un candidat
présidentiel non seulement un
ex-président mais un candidat qui est
dans une campagne active pour la
présidentielle la prochaine
présidentielle donc il y a ça également
à considérer qu'il fait en sorte que
personnellement je serais le dernier
surpris si Monsieur Trump sortait
rapidement après le scrutin pour
annoncer sa candidate voilà éviter
d'aller témoigner aussi la commission
sur le Capitole si ça tient toujours on
verra bien rendu là beaucoup de choses
regarder donc ce mardi 8 novembre ce
vendredi et Raphaël Jacob merci beaucoup
bonne fin de semaine merci merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI